we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's a
funny idea that someone has which i
there's actually more to it
let me explain after we listen hey David
I was just wondering if you've ever
thought about acting I can't be the only
viewer who would be interested in this
sitcom starring you and Jimmy from
Philly alright thanks have a great day
yeah so listen we actually got after the
last phone call I took from Jimmy from
Philly which is up on YouTube it was put
up there over the weekend if you've
missed it Jimmy from Philly is this very
angry Trump is who calls in and we
actually do sort of get along after my
last phone call with him a lot of people
wrote in and said David wouldn't it be
hilarious if Jimmy called in and like
presented a news story if you said Jimmy
I want you to present to my audience
some legislative thing that happened
some news story whatever it would be
absolutely hilarious just to see what he
would do with it and this is yet another
idea a sitcom with Jimmy from Philly and
me I love it I know a lot of people
don't like Jimmy from Philly every time
Jimmy from Philly is on I also get a lot
of emails that say David stop giving
this guy airtime if there's one thing
that I can say about Jimmy from Philly
other than I don't have a problem
getting along with him in conversation
he is an absolutely furious trumpet -
hates everything that is democratic left
whatever liberal whatever - progressive
you want to apply but he's a paid member
to the David Pakman show which is I
don't know what to make of it he's a
paid member and he has been for months
and he continues to support the show so
in any case I don't anticipate any
sitcoms with Jimmy from Philly but just
a little background on some of the
reactions to him we've got a great bonus
show coming up for you today two ways to
get access to the bonus show become a
member or become a patron david
pakman.com slash membership or
patreon.com slash david pakman show I
will see you then or otherwise on
tomorrow's show